louder with Crowder studios protected
exclusively by Walter and hopper
what a wonderful print and fake tacky
the media lies all day light harder like
fast are we supposed to know what the
truth is anymore
irrelevant obfuscation is key
it's the DNC sport
[Applause]
Oh
which lies they will be spreading
knowing where they're going senior
oh there d platforming
[Applause]
just then
doesn't matter once it's trending
not a shred of truth
from the investigations ongoing are the
overlords still accusing the president
the content to keep the monetizing
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that means that I have marks on my
knuckles because we have representative
Dan Crenshaw ladies and a lot of the
minimis dude you have been going people
love it it works for me we have my half
Asian lawyer bill Richmond in third
chair along with because we had a
booking error my mood Alma mood
Isis communications director how are you
sir doing well here again to show you
the softer side of ice I am very
appreciative you are here quarter black
eardrum good pass some jargon jr. what's
the wanted a bridesmaid red I still
don't buy it
20:22 not my question of the day ah let
me ask us was this president Trump's
breakthrough week of winning are you
tired yet if so what was your fate man
your favourite win this week also
notification squad please let us know if
you're subscribed you're alerted in
those patients how are you receiving
them because a lot of people say they're
not getting them we don't know what's
going on we need to know we can't play
by the rules don't we have represented
and Crenshaw we're going to get into the
top wins of this week with southern
Donald Trump so much so much winning
right now how do you feel about that in
the mood well you know a week where
you're winning is not a week where we're
winning so that's kind of why I'm here
yeah hell of a week for us the offering
different points of view like brian
Stelter is program leading the news who
weren't following the FBI is now
reportedly probing why charges against
Jesse Smollett were dropped has come to
the New York Post there's confusion as
to why charges were dropped even though
there was evidence for a conviction is
what they said many of us are confused
too thankfully the actor promises to
answer all the questions in his upcoming
tell-all if I totally did it
which seems and all sides by the way
point to a highly partisan decision made
by the district attorney's office it's
the suspicions that were all but
confirmed after this leaked phone call
oh yeah okay so we now do in fact have
the check the suspect paid the two
brothers with the suspect paid by check
okay got it and we now have the receipt
for the rope the brothers bought for the
noose for the staged attack okay noose
got it now the Department believes that
this in combination with all of the
other evidence should lead to an easy
conviction of Jesse Smollett
wait Jesse Smollett as an empire yes oh
my god I love that show well unless
you're a rich gay black guy apparently
so look I don't want to pile on anybody
who's having a bad day like he is just
he smiled like I would love to pile on
of course yes sir but he should
definitely get whatever penalty it comes
with what 16 charges yeah $10,000 and
what's 15 16 hours worth of community
service that be a half Asian lawyer bill
rich I mean he's got so many different
things you know the amount of money that
was spent by the city oh yeah dealing
with all of this is not even I mean
we're not coming in saying here that
with what he's done so far and Rahm
Emmanuel's pissed and going after that
money said he's actually gonna tally it
all up in cinema bill when Rahm Emanuel
gets pissed someone gets finger poke and
naked would be happening in Chicago if
Carla Winslow was still Asian there was
not a documentary film but it's tough to
know now with Amazon front they all
believe together in international news
New Zealand is now calling for citizens
to voluntarily surrender their guns
after the mosque shooting of an
estimated 1.2 million guns in the
country
the total number surrendered thus far is
37 Wow
ouch amazing so this comes from BuzzFeed
the Prime Minister reminds people that
quote to make our community safer the
time to act is now in a country where
there is one gun for every four people
or as seen after encouraging gun owners
to surrender their weapons one gun for
every four people they overreacted a
little bit with this but I love the
Newseum there's like 37 of us think
would happen yeah you know what we
definitely did me there was anyone
defending us with a gun exactly the
conclusion I think that guy should
donate his gun back yes Barney's the guy
that defended him and chased him off no
we tried something like this when we
overtook raka we did this whole you know
turn in your head thing nobody does it
nobody does it total failure that's true
well set it up I don't even know who
their prime minister is but I'm sure
he's free
turning she steal it and she who cares
it's an inconsequential country and now
they'll be pissed and I don't care
that's how you know turning to religion
the Pope for some reason really really
doesn't want anyone to kiss his ring
here you go when asked the Pope said oh
you have any idea where there's
Cardinals mouths have been it's been
like while he's
in the kitchen which by the way is why
one offered refused the syrup always
refused the syrup
in other news letter accredit obtained
exclusive audio from the probably what
he was weird to me is the people who can
clearly see up ahead in the line and
they try to fake him out for the Gordon
Bombay triple deke one lady she walks up
like I'm not going to get it man I get
it's flu season you know no if you
manage to scale the Vatican walls
hopefully you've had your flu shot by
the way well it don't work and
entertainment news Chris Evans now says
that he wouldn't play Tom Brady in a
movie as long as a Brady remained a
trump supporter the Hollywood Reporter
Dan to quote the actor if Brady still on
that Trump train I might have to cut
ties it's really tough
yeah really hard for ya this explains
recent comic-con leaks of Captain
America infinity twink we were wandering
for a bit that's a little bad right
there on the Trump train I mean what
does that even mean you can't support
the sitting president what more than
half of the people in the country do
that what are you now the thought police
like we can't even associate this did
this what is it that spiral of silence
that they talked about and not Germany
it's exactly how stuff like that start
compared to Nazi Germany for crying out
loud
am gonna do that because the trauma geek
on steroids on a subpar Marvel don't let
you even think about it ask people to
wear a mag ahead out there I would point
out that Chris Evans played the hitman
in
in the Iceman movie oh he did yes yeah
so that's kind of yes the ice the ice
man would eat pizza well dismembering
people Oh sick person honestly it
inspired me to get into violence you
know everybody has that moment yeah
pizza was my mind was David Letterman
and Wars was Iceman yeah wasn't there
another one not with that Chris Evans
but with what's-his-name the guy from
NYPD Blue is that really English name
but he's Latino he was in Sons of
Anarchy Gemma
that guy there was a large man Jamaa
that's all I know and someone's gonna
hear Gemma and they're gonna know I'm
talking about he was NYPD blue those
bags under his eyes anyways I think he
played Iceman another one finally
there's Nancy Pelosi before we get to
the winds of week and into blows people
pandering to a pack she confused Syria
with serial Hezbollah seeks to set up
terror networks on the border between
Israel and Syria
yeah quick to capitalize on the first
was Kellogg's terror networks on the
border between Israel and cereal
so before the show actually my mood was
kind enough to share with us some of the
most popular serials and in Syria in
actuality we didn't know yeah different
cultures so we're really preach ative
and we're glad to have you here and that
brings us to this week 7+1
you always forget the one in the chamber
if my half-asian way weren't
uncomfortable in this program after the
Pope bit this is yeah well go through
them these are the top seven plus one
most popular serials in Syria number
seven frooties pebbled yeah that's a
popular one that would seem to we grow
up yes yeah not necessarily healthful
number six burka brand which almost
seems as though it's redundant given the
previous one I think of my mood how
about you take a swing here too this is
number five most popular serial in Syria
[Music]
number four let's have a happier bill
Richmond number three fruit loops being
thrown off of building yes this is the
only one that's a good for as a
lunchtime or past they can't fly number
two actually total annihilation of the
Jews yet seems it's almost as though it
isn't a real cereal so much as it's the
expressed purpose in your charter
it's there's a theme yeah there's a
theme and the number one most popular
cereal in Syria right now rape nuts yes
and of course we always forget the one
of the chamber up my mood while you take
us out with the plus one well this one's
my my favorite one growing up was a
honey bunches of goats this week seven
buzz one
finanza turn back I don't know why feels
I need to repeat it when we clearly
known every time it's been drilled in
usually AB usually James Bond it's
usually that's where it comes from I
think I have no idea I just feel like
it's something you've heard in a lot of
films yes it's but I don't know who
forgets the one in the chamber not
anymore they don't know I have no idea
by the way did you hear that
Alexander Acacio Nina Pinta Santa Mira
Cortez she wants to ban all
semi-automatics oh yeah she just fit
that in there she's like high-capacity
magazines and semi automatics we don't
have this prep for the show but on her
tweet she says designed to kill people
because I like my gun is designed to not
kill people yeah I don't know I mean I
want him to hurt him a little bit I just
wonder when I pulled the trigger I
wanted to say stop can we test the
Walther to stun yes zone to be she just
shoehorns in all semi-automatic and that
means everything but a letter action
your pump pump shotguns and I don't know
would you hurt if she did recently right
she has she actually put her money where
her mouth is she actually asked all of
the congressional police who are around
her office to give up their guns I
thought you were telling the truth
because I would expect the fake news
from a mood because yeah last week's
trivia winner by the way was laura Van
Pelt who correctly answered that the
chosen drinking vessel among survivors
of the zombie apocalypse is well I guess
it's a mug I don't know how she won it
seems we're getting a little loose
giving away the mud clubs all right so
context here Donald Trump president
Chavez had an unusually good week as a
group of people here who've been critics
of the president when wrong I think it's
important to praise him when he's right
so we've actually rounded up the top
four of top four or five I think again
you tell us which one you think is the
most significant from this week so much
winning obviously the biggest one right
here is the mall or a poet so a key to
my year for the past two years two years
the left told us that Muller was closing
in on president it was basically right
it was inevitable the walls are closing
in I think of Donald Trump as
Titanic and Robert mower as the iceberg
so flowery his family and his aides
everyone in the Oval Office must go
[Applause]
comedy that is Chris Matthews dilib I
think of him as a Titanic and Muller as
the iceberg I also like to think of him
as a homeless man and Muller with a
sandwich only there's mold then I take
my pill with the TI I drank a bucket of
saltwater before this program you really
would really want to make sure you're
gonna be right if you're that flower in
your language if you really go that far
in I mean it just seems odd multiple
writers say well hold on a second maybe
we could spice up this analogy a little
bit no I like iceberg is the way to go
here oh really all of the theories
Berg's nowadays kids all you kids with
your Twitter's and your books of faces
in social media you don't know a good
iceberg analogy when you see one it's
all icebergs Carl hey all the growing
ice in Greenland right there's too much
of it now a big danger now it's gonna
sink more ships we should get rid of it
right but let's check in and see how
they're doing this week yeah yeah
when Barr released a four-page letter
summarizing it it was like the cliff
notes or more like I want to jump off a
cliff notes so let me make sure I
understand this mr. Colbert you want to
jump off a cliff because our president
didn't collude with a foreign power to
rig an election and they wonder why we
think the left hates America I know it
he wants to cut his wrists to Eliot
Smith's needle in the hay because we
found out that our president was honest
right he wasn't colluding with a foreign
power what else do you guys really want
right your basic argument now is that he
is guilty because we said it I saw
myself say it on the news last night it
must be real that's the argument I dream
to dream and I want it to be true was a
bummer looking for any opening arms
going to disagree I dreamed a dream
there was an iceberg someone let that
make air please if ever I'm doing
something this program alone we've done
things that are far away than that that
being said it still doesn't come across
as off-putting look all the way how all
these a progressive outlets they were
outraged wouldn't win rush limbaugh said
they hoped Obama would fail oh yeah
you're saying he's an American well we
were supposed to think that he'd
committed treason just because he wanted
Obama to
with a socialist agenda you won't get
into sweeping legislative control over
the fifth US economy record job low
participation you know what that kind of
thing yeah exactly
he just wanted to fail at implementing
an agenda but now it's fine to wish that
the president was a Russian asset just
because it would be a point to your
political team and these are the same
people who talk about political division
this is why I don't want to find common
ground how do you find common ground
with someone who is bummed that our
president didn't collude with Putin yeah
and he's not for socialism that's
totally fine by the way like a silver
lining to Bernie he's brought all the
socialists kind of out of the closet
it's actually kind of a nice thing
Acacio cortez as well yeah they're out
in front now back in Obama's day when
they like Limbaugh is saying socialism
it's not socialism now it's like yeah
they said they said I think they're
saying socialism because I can't say the
n-word it was yeah yeah see all of the
noted socialists throughout history were
black people and then right away when
they say yeah well you're raising
socialism and race are you racist
against Obama okay give me an example of
successful socialism why does country
ever Norway yeah let's go with that
Denmark you prefer you prefer Iceland
there are icebergs over there it's a
great country win number two Michael
avenatti and I just need to hold on just
say it and let it ride I don't need to
say any more but I'll explain it because
you know I feel like you guys are
working on this is the lawyer
representing stormy Daniels a pornstar
so we got all Trump Julie this is stormy
Daniels they don't number Julie sweat
Nick she was one who accused yeah
Cavanaugh of running quaalude rape gangs
in high school European that phrase
actually made headland
accused sitting Supreme Court justice of
running quaalude
rape gang what do you mean what I don't
remember the headline I remember the
story I'm still waiting to see how it
turns out this one caught me off guard I
really felt that this guy was was it was
a good guy you know I did half asian
bail did you know anything about
avenatti before this no other than other
before storming no no not much I don't
know if you know you ran in the same
circles
no no not often he runs in circles keep
in mind this is some
this is what we want we want to go pre
and post avenatti was supposed to be
Trump's worst nightmare yeah and by the
way here brian Stelter which I still
don't get here brian Stelter tell it a
serious presidential contender here
remember this well you know if anyone
knows a con I guess it would be Donald
Trump
this guy has were you credibility in the
eyes of most Americans and certainly in
the eyes of the world he's the control
Wow the Dominos of all these legitimate
news and I truly believe that this is
the Achilles heel of the president
looking at the 2021 reason why the new
seriously other contender is because of
your presence on cable news more
transparent Stelter by the way the
reason that I think would be great that
you were in office is because you do my
show fat bald and gay is no way to go
through life son I don't get who lost
someone at CNN had to pick between brian
Stelter and someone there was someone
else
there was a lot of more than the people
that I have to kiss the Pope's ring and
someone said you mister Stelter that's
got to be the worst second place ever
I get why you guys watch and hate
America when you watch our news yeah I
don't know I see Stelter I feel like it
almost reminds me of your wrestling
where you have the good the heel maybe a
little bit a little bit he's like a
player I guess or Jesse Ventura's got so
distracted by so someone please explain
to me this Delta thing here's the thing
like I've talked about school choice I
don't understand the case for it I can
understand the case for Bill Maher I
certainly understand the case from John
Stewart I know you guys don't like
Colbert I think Colbert can be very
funny I understand Anderson Cooper okay
I get it he was great on the mole I
understand
Don Lemon because you know he seems like
he could be in intelligence sometimes as
well brian Stelter has please someone
make a case for any redeeming quality
for this man he makes everyone else
around him look much smarter and I just
read today that he's straight okay
I just how could we know I got arrested
for twenty million dollar extortion plot
against Nike embezzling clients money
defining a bank could spend life in
prison if convicted actions so you know
the good news for avenatti is that
dreams do come true all of my sexual
fantasies involve handcuffs he opens a
sex dungeon by the way really quickly
before you feel sorry for him don't ya
know yeah it's hard in general for us to
feel sorry for lawyers sorry half asian
lawyer bills all right and I I'm asking
is anybody coming to his defense at all
like it's it's been good it's for this
Jeremy Daniel I'm under the box
I know but normally the left kind of
comes out and tries to kind of make
everything happen and no one everybody
just he stepped forward and everybody's
like a hundred yards behind him this is
what we'll get to this at the end of
this whole segment it is amazing that
the media is not talking about this
really I mean this guy he was a
centerpiece yeah I'm meeting for a long
long time Kavanagh you couldn't hear
without a Bernard a were saying Oh
Donald Trump up they just assumed the
store McDaniels thing was and I'll be
honest I said at that point my yeah it's
a 50/50 shot
that being said even if there's a 50/50
shot that's something did happen with
stormy Daniels now no one will believe
you because you're Michael avenatti
when numbers this is a big one for me
this is probably the biggest one for the
green you've heard us talk about it I've
read that you can watch in the channel I
read the whole green new deal in its
entirety unedited this was supposed to
be the legislative darling of the left
climate change in our environmental
challenges the biggest that's the key
word attention technology to do it we
have the obligation we have now peridot
no we just need the political will to
get this done I support a green new deal
okay and I want to tell you why climate
change is an existential threat
today we say to Donald Trump and the
fossil fuel industry their climate
change is not a hoax but its word
massive threat an existential ty via our
country and the entire planet
apparently our greatest exid enchi let
tallies up to a whopping zero votes of
support right and she said afterwards
that was a strategy I don't understand
the vote present strategy looks a heck
of a lot worse than these zero yes votes
my it is remarkable to me exact and they
say they say it's a political stunt this
was a thing like it's a political stunt
to put it to a vote without a hearing so
is introducing a five-page bill that
takes over the entire American economy
because we want quote a smart grid with
no definite how long did it take you to
read that by the way 60 minutes 60 look
into watching reddit instant to 16
minutes to read they'll monetize yes
I'll hold
oh it's never monetized what do you
think they just green new deal and they
said Oh crowd Audrey New Deal is matched
up with an algorithm of screws fourth
win this week president Trump's
emergency declaration so for people
haven't really been following the
timeline and this is kind of difficult I
think for a lot of people back in
February present Trump declared a
national emergency
order get funds for the border wall
Congress voted to reject the declaration
then he vetoed the rejection this week
president Trump's veto of their blocking
was upheld and a billion dollars it's on
its way to the border as we speak
pallets of cash base and we'll talk with
congressman Crenshaw about this because
some Republicans are divided on this I
actually do this is I think that's an
issue of national security he does have
the authority what do you think
half-asian alaric lachemann absolutely I
mean there's there's not there's no
question I mean I've said this before
I've got family no past so when you go
to pass when you look right there
between the border of America and Juarez
Mexico is a wall and no one is saying
that there has to be an exact same wall
across the entire border though that
there needs to be security so putting a
billion dollars into something as
important as regulating what can come in
this country both from a physical sense
or a person sense yes been the policy
strategy of every single nation that has
ever existed or that hopes to exist or
keep in existence right so it
this is really two wins and one for him
when you're president you pull out your
first veto that's a big deal that's
putting everything kind of on the line
because if you lose that you're pretty
powerless after that yeah so he was able
to sustain the veto and he's getting his
border walls yes is huge
veto stings but to brian Stelter may be
the billion dollars going to a black of
the south we pronounce them south south
south south solve doesn't sound right
I don't all I know is you pronounce Nike
right earlier so that was a nice a
pronouncing correctly all the time I
know it's supposed but I often say post
a post
it's like sounds like I'm saying should
post like Jodie Foster yeah and I know
how to say it right you're probably
stupid I almost put like Nike with like
5yz after it just to help yeah just read
it out I'm at a clinic thank you know
that's what the children say when they
jump from the fourth storey window at
the factory what's your the ISIS palace
an unnatural and I think this is where I
feel like more of a Democrat because I I
don't want you to have a wall first of
all and also I I agree in part with some
of the statements made as far as the
climate the green New Deal people I do
think that your days are numbered mm-hmm
and just just ours yes just just the
Great Satan and a little by the way you
guys cannot see how funny my vision
blurred but he's positively tickled take
this whole time that's the mood
it doesn't matter where you stand in
Republicans have this debate
conservatives that is debated by the
national emergency and I think it's a
healthy debate to have that's a good
example where we can find common ground
and have a healthy debate
regardless of where you line up this is
definitely a win from president Trump's
perspective but you you don't have to
take my word for it we have two national
emergencies one declared on the southern
border where the president transfers and
Tate is taking away millions of dollars
from other agencies to address a wall
which doesn't even solve these issues
why
why are we gonna waste billions of
dollars on a medieval fortress that
won't work I urge my colleagues to vote
and override the veto leading president
I'm well convinced than ever that the
president's actions are not only
unlawful they are deeply is mr. peebody
wall is it immorality or it's not who we
are as a nation
mr. Peabody was that boo boo I think
it's the same guy
no yogi here's the year even as people
were saying that trumps chanting they
were gone for 20 20 yeah the people
saying three weeks this is why you have
to look at the long ball of politics
didn't look at this week you'd have to
make a very different prediction than
you would have made three weeks ago and
that's why the media where are they
right now nut go check Huffington Post
go check box go check Washington Post
and see if they're talking about the
wall being built completely being
exonerated from the model report and
have a knotty
there quietly slipping away green new
teal and you know what I just I think
it's time I'm exhausted I will tell you
frankly I'm exhausted I am tired from
all this winning and I'm going to take a
nap and then after dish will have the
will have Crenshaw yeah a little bit of
Reb sleep so so bunch of winning
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you'd have dined in French I'm insulting
him or his mother he was a lotta raped
it goes up girls consonant truck stops
for who then de plat floor arming ready
we're on step did that bad tap that
means in French usually I'm down to a
French I'm insulting him or his mother
you know there's a lot of rape that goes
up in rural was causing a truck stops
did you understand me the implication NN
will you join up at louder with Crowder
calm slash mug club or are you a bat
muncher the suspense is killing me
hello as many of you know this week I
was quite sick I had to get a surgery on
my toes infection
right after the anesthesia I started
shaking him convulsing like Michael J
Fox and I told the world I was at the
hospital for four days during which time
I lost six pounds and showed up my IV
and catheter but they cleared me to go
home and now I'm giving it a little
abyss and a little bit and I'm back
fighting putz and now I can say at four
months old I am officially the most
expensive prepared the wild and they
still don't know exactly what's wrong
with me so as shameless as it sounds if
you want my continued medical care and
you don't what Betty prouder today join
Laurelwood protic back come slash
why I oughta there's no point in your
pockets are tasty smooth creamy
[Music]
I just realized that went the wrong way
on that where I'm supposed to do this
and lean into it here like the Hogan but
I leaned in this way my gosh which I
think means you know that I'm
functionally [ __ ] I think it means
that there's a serious problem and I'm
in trouble and I'm a troll because our
next guest really classes up the show Oh
elegant guest and a lot of our fans have
been asking for him to be on let me just
give him his intro because a lot of
people complain if we don't give them
the intro but I one already knows who he
is they've been they've been all the
Twitter so what I did there oh alright
he is a representative from Texas second
congressional district I wouldn't have
gotten the number right otherwise oh
yeah I just know he's representative but
more importantly more interesting Lee a
former Navy SEAL officer who earned two
Bronze Star medals Purple Heart went to
Harvard after military service and a lot
of people know you know he lost his
right eye serving in Afghanistan
certified due to an AED you can follow
him on the Twitter at rep Dan Crenshaw
representative Crenshaw thank you for
being here sir
sorry tycoon Crenshaw you told me before
the break awesome be with you I am very
glad to have you here and just to get it
the discomfort right out of the way and
I'm going to be hypocritical how
annoying is it that everyone always asks
you about your eyepatch first knowing
that I just did that oh well no one's as
annoying as you I guess I really am
Davidson threw you a few jabs and I
topped the list I feel horrible about
myself oh you're great I'm a big fan I'm
a big fan
now I I don't mind it's it's it's part
of my story and and frankly being in
politics is telling your story because
you do have to connect with people in
order to to to get them to believe that
you should represent them there has to
be some kind of human connection and and
sharing a part of yourself with them is
a big part of that so I'd surely expect
it right well I appreciate how
level-headed you are I want to get to
that and as it relates to Trump a little
bit but since we led with that you know
Pete Davidson obviously got in trouble
for mentioning your eye patch on
Saturday Night Live and I remember a lot
of conservatives were outraged saying he
needed to be fired then you appeared
with him and buried the hatchet pretty
pretty quickly
that's not
but we're held to that same standard as
a comedy show we're often I say listen I
don't want to think you want to take
everything that we say 100% seriously
what inspired that because that is
counterculture to the outraged society
in DC both on the right and left yeah
and it's something we gotta fix in this
country because it's out of control
um so you know well of course you know
going back in time a little bit just so
everybody understands you know there was
there was certain elements of his joke
that were like no they were kind of
funny but you know kind of offensive but
like you know we first he said that I
looked like a hit man in a porno and I
was like okay I'm curious of what kind
of kind of films you're watching but I
was like yeah I just you know is this a
genre like there's just I think he just
went down a vanadis client list and just
searched those that wasn't the part that
like God everybody riled up it was it
was the part after that maybe he
misspoke maybe it was scripted funny I
who knows but he just said I know he
lost his eye or or whatever right it was
dismissive that's what that's what
that's what made everybody angry so woke
up the next day and you know the to a
bunch of texts from friends and you know
noting that this had happened and we
kind of watched the media outrage sort
of play out there there were a lot of
there was a lot of outrage for and that
was expected to make a comment on it and
I couldn't I can't fake outrage right
yeah I'm not I'm not good at we have
very dark senses of humor in the SEAL
Teams
coupled with that so we're pretty used
to having thick skin and so I I have to
admit I was not I did not take some kind
of emotional toll on me that the
frustration what that was the fact that
I had to deal with it at all but but I
saw I just kind of said what I felt
which is like listen tone try hard not
to offend people but also try not to be
offended I think that's a good way to
live Y this world and and you know just
because our society at this moment tends
to value and and I'm saying elevate the
sort of victimhood mentality and elevate
this aggrieved the victim status it's
the cops man if I could just be an
aggrieved victim then I'll really be
right then I'll win that's it kind of a
terrible place for our culture to be
right and I don't
be part of that and so there was just
there was no reason to demand apologies
for for any of this nonsense
right that's a really good point not a
lot of politicians we make that point on
this show but yeah the the seeking
affliction as you see with people out
there and people so why would anyone
want to be in this and then insert
minority class of the day here I go oh I
don't know because you could get off
faking hate crimes for starters you know
but rich Hollywood so it's across the
board at that point let me kind of
moving on let me ask you this how have
you become I mean obviously as a
freshman representative and we use that
term a lot but so popular despite being
one if I would say the few balanced view
points out there if people follow your
social media on President Donald Trump
you know a lot of people are seen as
either never Trump or they're seen as
Mogga hot where my hat wearing it
doesn't matter what he does you praise
him where he's right and you know you
called him out you criticize when he was
talking about John McCain recently and
criticizing him and lobbing some some
attacks after after he had died how do
you remain so popular because there
aren't many people who seem to figure
out that equation well I mean we have
another poll I don't know that I'm so
popular I can tell you with our viewers
and our readers yeah they love you I
hope so you know because I think people
respect intellectual consistency and
honesty they just want you to tell you
why you're saying what you're saying
they don't want they don't want to feel
like it's just part of a political
calculation and so the way to avoid it
looking like it's part of the political
calculation is it for it not to be a
political calculation and for it to
actually be true right okay and and and
and wasn't I I don't take swipes the
president just to do it okay a lot of
never Trump errs just do that right I
think they do it just because it's
become part of their brand and they just
can't help themselves and they forget
the defend conservatism so that's a real
problem because a lot of what President
Trump does is conservative a lot of the
way he governs is conservative minutes
good
there's some things I disagree with it
should be really simple to simply say
well I disagree with those things I'm
not a you know I'm not a sycophant I'm
not just following blindly yeah well you
know that's a that segues into
interesting point first off I love that
beta work had to respond to your tweet
in an interview with was it was it Chris
Hayes and I don't have to rip
it's actually called about on that which
is interesting yeah I yeah Chris Hayes
I'm still by the way if anyone could
explain the brian Stelter thing to me
please let me know I still don't get it
we just talked about that a couple I
don't understand it
I don't get it I love that he was forced
to respond because of your social media
but let me ask you this you you've also
held a position on the the constant at
the the border crisis right a lot of
people have talked about the
constitutionality of that in the state
of emergency
you were just explaining this to me
during the the brief break what is your
stance and how do you justify it as a
consistent conservative because I'm it
may surprise a lot of people yeah I've
got a series of things I want to point
out to my conservative colleagues who I
think rightfully have concerns over okay
so there's there's a there's a couple
arguments right one is that it's not an
emergency okay well the counter-argument
to that is well yes it is an emergency
and the numbers dictate that it is okay
last month there was you know a sixty
six thousand apprehensions I depend on
you measure that almost eighty thousand
just last month yeah yesterday was
reported that we're gonna be highest
amount of daily illegal crossings in 13
years the other reason it's an emergency
and a humanitarian emergency at that is
because it's because our system is
designed to encourage immigrants to drag
children across because they know if
they bring a child across they get let
go into the population we'd have a whole
new generation of dreamers being created
right because of that and and that
constitutes a crisis all right there's
more family units being apprehended than
ever before so that's the problems in an
emergency yes is it different than it
was even a year ago yes absolutely there
is a different situation okay so that's
that part then there's the
constitutionality of it now there's
there's there's there's there's two
elements of the Constitution that I
believe but up against each other here
and you pretty much have to decide which
one you value more on this side you have
the appropriations part okay that's
Article one right Congress is in charge
of appropriating money you can't just
take you can't just change that now
technically the president is
reprogramming money he's not taking it
out of its Treasury like the
Constitution says thank you but that's
just a okay that's a technicality who's
the other but though which says that the
president needs to faithfully execute
the law that's article two what law are
we talking about well how about US code
1325 which is so popular you are is this
your computer letting you know
that everyone's texting you right now
all right yeah good I wish I could make
that if I mute that I wonder if I mute
you that's the problem that's okay well
deal with it because we love because
you're so cuddling you were talking
about so yes you were going to the
president baster you got into the
constitutionality article one and now
we're going to you're going over to the
president and what kind of falls under
his legitimate purview I believe is
where you met exactly we want you to
faith let's get the law and 1325 is a
law and says you cannot cross the border
illegally and so it's not being enforced
right now is the president's job to
enforce it so again those two but up
against each other I value that one I
value the one that says we have to
protect our country over over this over
this other one which is an
appropriations law that was passed by
Congress so that coupled with the
national emergencies act itself which
clearly gives it puts it in writing and
statute to use to use that act and in
that way I think we've got a pretty good
case yeah I would agree with you and
that actually would be one of the few
areas where people could look at
executive orders and say as it relates
to national security or national
emergency that's what the role of the
president is effectively it should be
limited but if it deals with national
security obviously that that he's called
a couple the commander in chief for a
reason and I think it does come down to
I guess the gray area of whether you
consider the border crisis of national
emergency I think you've made a very
strong case and this brings me to
something else here there are a lot of
similarities between you and go with me
here so don't take offense to it right
away because what I'm about to say is
way worse than what Pete Davidson said
but I'm gonna bring it all back home
some similarities here between
Alexandria Cascio Nina Pinta Santa Maria
Cortez in that you are both new fresh
faces social media is a huge portion of
your platform very influential both seen
as firebrand but I think there are some
differences here which really sort of
draw a significant line in the sand as
to how the people conservatives embrace
versus the left in that namely you're
articulate pragmatic not a doomsday
theorist in the same way that that Nina
Pinta Santa Maria Cortez is and open you
openly lists references sources you know
you're talking about the border crisis
you listed charts on Twitter I think
Cortez respond to me on Twitter and just
say we'll look it up in a second why
don't you show
we you made the claim have you heard
these simpler these comparisons before
and do you see it as a good thing
something that you embrace III think no
I was hoping you just continue your list
of compliments but you know I can't go
on forever
okay yeah and if you can't go on that
long but you know we get up there I can
I can make sure to make you feel very
comfortable I'm married by the way
people are gonna take that the wrong way
I mean I'll make you feel comfortable
and coming back because f ed took it the
room yeah I took it the wrong I
apologize hey Ted Cruz came down hey
four times no I I made I I always take
it slight amount of Defense people say
that but I do understand what people
mean by it it's it's a matter of media
attention we're both young both
Millennials were both I think trying to
drive a future for our party I'm really
happy with the future that I'm that that
mean my colleagues talk about for our
party I'm not I'm not so sure they have
those that same kind of unity over on
that side you know and and and endless
it you brought up something which is
defend what you're saying you know yeah
and and and unfortunately we're getting
too comfortable in this in this culture
with it with this idea of kind of bold
ignorance right where it's just like if
you're if you're if you if you're
emotional about it if you're genuine if
you're authentic then the facts don't
matter right right now I think she's
actually said that in an interview yeah
those lines rocks and Huffington Post so
that even if Cortez was either Vox
Huffington Post it might have been
Washington Post so I don't know exactly
but we did a piece on it not that long
ago where he said it doesn't matter if
she hasn't ironed out all the details
because she's morally right
she's fundamentally morally right and
for me I go how do you know that you're
morally right the facts should line up
with how you feel the facts should line
up with how your remoting and if they
don't at all well chances are you're
probably morally incorrect but they
grant her and especially the media I
know this sounds like a tired trope but
you deal with this all the time as a
conservative the media really does prop
this up and assume the moral high ground
to someone like like a OC yeah well they
operate from a different premise I mean
if you're like for instance if you're
looking at a green new deal and your
offer
from a premise of the entire world
ending 12 years well then then there's
no cost as too much right so they so
they they use that they they they
configure the data and their arguments
in a way to to assume that if you
disagree with them then you are morally
corrupt right that's a real problem that
means it means you're not having you're
not having an intellectual conversation
you know and they accuse conservatives
and Republicans of doing that with
global terrorism like oh you're
fear-mongering hold on a second I would
say that there is reason for legitimate
concern and I would have maybe defer to
you since you've obviously served in our
military my injury only came from
crashing a Jeep on the way to an AIDS
Walk so not exactly the same thing but
um global terrorism more of a concern to
me than the reality of the world ending
in 12 years if we don't pass a five-page
bill five pages five pages yeah I've
been what is true what is not and um you
know and more recently what they did
that with was was simply the border
right there's no Christ there's nothing
to see here I mean we heard this over
and over and over again this mantra of a
manufactured crisis and like again I can
just lay out the numbers you know when
you have 400,000 people crossing
illegally last year these are just
apprehended by the way Border Patrol
thinks they maybe get one in three yeah
that's an enormous number I don't have
to call them bad people I don't have to
say that there there might be terrorists
among them and this is where our
messaging gets screwed up I think as
conservatives sure I call them all
criminals okay I mean technically
they're conducting criminal acts i
crossing border legally well let's just
assume that they're all good people
hundred percent yeah it's an
unsustainable it's an unsustainable
inflow of people right you because you
come in here we have to be putting these
kids into our schools or using emergency
rooms there's a cost on society and it's
also impossible to to to integrate them
into our society there's a second thing
that people don't talk conservatives
don't say enough is you're cutting in
front of the line in front of legal
immigrants who deserve to be in this
country because we do want immigrants in
this country and we can have a valid
conversation about whether we should up
our quote illegal immigrants but but
there really shouldn't be any discussion
over whether we should have illegal
immigrants coming into the well that
sounds about like something a white male
millennial would say but I'll let the
audience make their own judgement here
I have to ask you about a couple more
things would you have to get going
relatively soon you just introduced a
bill to include family leave for
Millennials you introduced it I believe
on on Wednesday can you can you explain
that to people who may not understand it
and where they can go to learn more
about it
senator Rubio and representative Ann
Wagner have been working on this for
quite a while now
senator Romney was was there the press
conference as well to supporting this so
really proud to be a part of this
basically it's it's an understanding
that and I think this is this is an
overarching theme I will point out
sometimes the left is not always wrong
about the problems they point out and
what they want they're just almost
always wrong about the solutions they
propose okay so it leaves a pretty good
example of that right a family that's
not a terrible thing in and of itself I
would love for four new young parents to
be able to have some kind of financial
cushion if they're gonna have their
first baby especially when they're in
their 20s or 30s or even you know you're
getting your start in life all right
Millennials understand this and and and
you know it's important to point out the
millennial generation not because this
bill is just for Millennials but because
we could probably as Millennials we
could buy it make the most use of it
right so the question is how do you pay
for something like this because the
Democrats solution is wealth giant
government program billions and billions
and billions and billions of dollars
completely unsustainable the very people
were trying to help we're gonna a debt
them to do it well that's a terrible
solutions not very creative and pretty
much pertain for most of the solutions
they propose for just about every
problem that they think is a problem
okay but let's assume this is a problem
because I think it is and we're
pro-family right I want the family unit
to thrive so what this allows is it
allows you to borrow from your future
Social Security funds basic and I'll
give you the simplest explanation of it
basically you take three months of
family leave okay now you have to back
up your your your your retirement by a
similar amount of time to pay it back
now you have other options to pay it
back - yeah you can pay it back sooner
if you'd like you can they pay it back
in lengthier payments if you'd like but
it doesn't change the the long-term
budget doesn't change the long-term
health of Social Security either it just
changed that we form like the the
the short-term health but not the
long-term and that's important so we're
we're basically the way I put it you're
borrowing from someone richer than
yourself which is you in the future
because you've actually had time to make
it in this world so it's like Timecop
with entitlements it's a really good way
to put it yeah me use that yeah there
you go perfect and also I may be a
little bit of demolition man with
entitlements of mentality sure the whole
damn damn catalogue really interesting
movie at the time I know it district it
was demolition man Stallone yes it was
Oh with Snipes in time cop no right I
have no idea I know time got with Van
Damme but for some reason I'm thinking
he was also in demolition matter I know
Snipes I think Snipes was in both the
point I don't want to muddy the waters
on your brilliant proposal here with my
stupid commentary we do plie on here so
final thing one thing I love to have a
tweet right here from you to
representative Adam Schiff for you said
that he said he had direct evidence of
Trump Russia collusion and this is
important because it's putting a fine
point on it he didn't say maybe there's
a possibility he said that he had direct
evidence of Trump Russia collusion that
means it's a lie
and he's doubling down still right this
is important for people to maintain a
timeline and this is why like you said
intellectual consistency is important
because we need to hold people to the
same standard that they would hold out
and if you say listen we need to
investigate someone for collusion at for
closure for Russia Russian collusion Tec
Kaluza could be a country could be a
city in a country I have no idea
then we news okay by that same standard
if you've claimed you have evidence we
might need to investigate you so this is
a springboard to say what would you say
is president Trump's biggest win of the
week would it be them all a report would
it be avenatti if you had to list them
and rank them man it's been a pretty
good way for the president is I think
he's taken and he's just kicking his
feet up right now and did well deserved
because it really did all it really did
all come down to like one moment where
where the molar report no found that
there was no collusion it's not he got
arrested which is do a little
disappointing for some of us who would
have liked to see him jump into the
presidential primary and along with
every other demo
rat but you're not going to be booked
for that and a few bad you know it just
just to watch all that take place happy
for the president III think it's a good
when his veto was not overridden either
should be seeing some money coming to
the come and come into wall funding
which I think we need and I think we're
gonna send it to the right places I
think just uh west west of el paso's is
the last I heard on that and I don't
think that'll hurt our military
readiness either based on where I'm
seeing that money gonna come from for
disaster preparedness so these are all
these are all good things the
president's making good on his promises
to actually secure our country we have
all found out that he indeed did not
collude with Russia that never really
thought he did but it looks like we have
now have a lengthy investigation that
shows that he did not and Democrats
really need to accept that one thing one
thing I want to say about out of the
ship its he used his position on the
Intelligence Committee to make everybody
believe that he had access to
information that he really did it
yes that's that is straight that's
beyond dishonest it's one thing to just
kind of say it the politicians always do
but he really you really uh he abused
his position and then that's really
problem yeah and you know sometimes
President Trump can come across a little
nutty but I think that anyone would lose
their marbles a little bit when people
are out there claiming that you've done
something that you haven't done I think
anyone would go a little bit nuts in the
public eye or they're gonna horse and
you're trying to obstruct justice
what obstruct what there's no crime and
their efforts like well there's no crime
but maybe obstruction we don't know you
could shift shift shift that's how I
feel but I will say this we have to get
going and I am tired and you must be
exhausted from all the winning it's so
much I think people are getting tired
people can file you a trap Dan Crenshaw
is there anywhere else that you would
like to plug real quick yeah well at rep
Dan Crenshaw I got another Twitter
account at Dan Crenshaw TX we use them
both they're both great follows please
follow both Instagram Dan Crenshaw TX
and just search for Dan crunch on
Congress and Crenshaw thank you so much
for being here sir I appreciate it we
must go we're gonna wrap this up in a
nice ribbon we'll be back after this
[Music]
[Music]
ladder with router Ranger pants why
yours today
louder with prouder shop cop one live
read of the week time this is where I
tell you about our sponsor Walter in mug
club even yeah you know I I like you I
like you and I see you do these reads
you're doing it all wrong okay do you
I'm not entirely comfortable with that I
I can do it I can do it
I am media training okay okay alright
alright
mahmoud al mahmoud here to tell you all
about mug club
it's a wonderful mug right and if we
don't receive your ninety nine dollars
in the next 48 hours we will inflict
unspeakable harms on it okay i don't
think that no that doesn't that's not
right no it's a proven method I'm not oh
I I made a mistake sorry okay 69 for
students and active military but if we
don't receive it we would inflict
unspeakable no the thing is we want the
mug to get to them intact listen you're
not only do you get to hand edged mug
you get access to the entire blaze
catalog ladders credit.com slash mug
Club as you do get the hand etched
girthy mug you get the daily there's a
lot of content we don't want to hurt
them up I guess well each that hand
still yes I like it
perfect $99 yeah right the way okay can
you hook me up with like a welfare I I
would but I'm not sure how comfortably
our funding foreign caliphates
let me get this Smith & Wesson yeah well
he made a Smith & Wesson chef writer you
can't please everyone
[Music]
[Music]
that was the blobfish
we've never seen a blobfish they're
disgusting oh yeah the blobfish is
there's no reason but I just you know I
didn't you know I didn't really feel
like doing the drowning dancing it that
much energy because damn Crenshaw really
took it out of me no representative
dancringe it looks too bad asking all
the time I need to issue an apology
before I get to the the closing segment
here Johnny Depp I'm sorry I'm sorry
Jenna I have given Johnny Depp a rough
time because I do think he's kind of
douchey but yeah when he was accused of
beating amber is Amber Heard and Amber
Heard up a little bit I think we had a
bit about that at that point it wasn't
really weren't really condemning him but
his drunken tirade brie threw that turns
out she kicked his ass yes so I hope
that guy just did you I hope you take it
for everything she's worth though really
probably taking yourself for everything
you're worth because probably a joint
checking a house account in that house
well let's be honest so this week and
you can bring it up there uh Garrett for
those who didn't follow early I was
subject to my first auto accident as a
passenger I should say when I was a kid
I was hit by a car once oh yeah yeah
look at the whole dashboard just explode
the airbags those were not friendly eyes
by the way yeah I was it was a higher
blue on an older Jeep who are exiting on
a loop from one freeway to another it's
hard for me to explain but basically
here's a freeway you need to get on this
freeway okay and there's a loop and the
loop comes running get on this freeway
and then there are only two lanes where
you're what and basically these two
lanes one lane is trying to get over on
the side of the freeway
the freeway that goes west and the other
one people are trying to get over on
another loop that goes downward going
north-south and I've had to do this exit
many times I've always thought it was
incredibly dangerous so when the tire
blew
while we were take I would obviously I
panicked looking at it now doesn't look
so bad thank God and it really was not
as bad as it could have been we're
fortunate that actually ironically the
complete spin out of the car which could
potentially increase the force of the
implemented in the concrete girder yeah
I think caused it to scrape a little bit
which cradled saved you a little bit the
the crash
I mean the frame is totaled thank you to
concrete that was like oh yeah the frame
is completely well it's about a Jeep
with a metal bumper and Gompers
completely broken the middle
steel frame completely cracked bent so
and she breaks my heart because Johnny
boy was driving love said she but it
could have been a lot worse thank God
he's fine he'll get another Jeep so I
said us to explain to you what happened
and to let you know that I understand
that this isn't exactly a scrape with
death as many car accidents could be but
at the time I didn't know that so at
that moment in time feeling the tire
blow out in one of the most difficult
loops in Texas all I knew was just pop
spin screech and with each spin I can
just see two lanes behind us the two
lanes which one of which is going very
very fast and the other people are
coming in on a blind loop and then spin
spin spin that concrete garter spin spin
spin girl cars going by and it felt like
they were getting faster and then the
concrete Carter was getting faster as it
came into view I thought it might be I
really thought it might be curtains in
retrospect no but it's kind of like that
kayak story that I've told you about
before I think it's where I was sure
that death yeah just like my parents
were gonna be on shore and just I
couldn't turn the kayak over it was one
of those old you know what the sealskin
kind ever before not these open guys
expressing their yes especially you have
no idea you said of cottage me I'm gonna
go out the smart design let's let's
stick you inside of a kayak and you
can't get out well they need to be
watertight back in the day yeah that's
what they didn't yeah but I even think I
bring it up because obviously I didn't
die in a kayak I wasn't dying this
cartridge but at that moment I thought
this might be it this is how it ends um
and I got that kind of flash at people
to I wouldn't in my life flash before my
eyes but let me explain it in this short
moment like count million different
thoughts were going through my head
after it happened and I kind of got to
download I was how did I think of all
these things at that second so first off
was obviously my god just please
straighten out and then I thought this
exit is the worst and I really think of
this is that like damnit this exit is
the worst city engineering in history
and then I thought I'm never traveling
in an old Jeep with crappy felt seats
again and then I thought all okay we're
definitely spinning out and then I
thought God just please let us crash him
or not into these two lanes and I
thought oh my god we're gonna crash and
now I just really hoped another car
doesn't come and hit us and then it hit
me okay I could I could die right here
remember that thought going through my
head this could happen
and the odd thing is I was oddly
accepting of it and sometimes in those
moments it's it's kind of a silly but
perfect example of ego you try to almost
strike a bargain with God and I remember
thinking you know what in this month
this really in this moment I'm
everything death would be okay
I just don't want to get hurt so let me
die that's fine but just don't let me be
crippled or maimed or pried out with the
jaws of life on a nightly news in a
quadrant view and then there was the
moment when the the airbags went off I
mean these are mid-90s airbags not they
were certainly not soft it wasn't like
being cradled in your loves bosoms at
all these were decidedly unfriendly
aggressive airbags they went off causing
my head to what I can only imagine was
like getting paddled back and forth
between the unsupportive bucket seats
like a pinball just came and I couldn't
hear anything
everything went completely white things
slowly kind of came back into view and
sounds warped back in smoke was coming
out of the - I think was the airbag gas
I don't know I've never had airbags
deployed before certainly not in the I
don't know it's a 90s model Jeep I think
it was total sensory deprivation and I
couldn't really move when I came to and
there was a moment there where I thought
oh crap I'm still here but I can't move
cars are coming they're gonna hit us and
then I thought oh crap I'm still here I
don't know how bad this is going to be
and I can't move and we're being upset
about it and thinking about it now it's
pretty disgusting I'm pretty disgusted I
thought that and sometimes there are
aspects of yourself that you can't
really fully understand until you're put
in that kind of a scenario but isn't
that the way it often goes in life many
times will do anything just to avoid the
pain sometimes we'd rather take the loss
the finality of defeat or in this case
I'll take death instead of being in a
wheelchair it sounds silly but I
remember thinking that we'll take that
finality rather than the pain of the
struggle and I think I know why at least
in my case and trying to deconstruct
some of this because I had afterward
there was a lot of a cornucopia of
adrenaline induced visceral emotive
reactions and many of you watching the
show know that I'm not a big fan of
cliches not that
friendly sound bites but usually because
they're often untrue and in this case
one that comes to mind we hear a lot is
people aren't afraid of being powerless
there they're more afraid of being more
powerful than they can possibly imagine
something along those lines neither one
of those things is true no one wants to
be powerless and I can attest to in that
moment in time sort of I was trying to
control aspects of the uncontrollable
but I think the reason that many of us
will find the out look for it take the
defeat over the pain of the struggle is
because we all find comfort in the idea
that our limitations our burdens or even
our ultimate defeats are completely out
of our control right if I if I remember
that if I die I die that it's just my
time that's out of my hands but if I
don't the balls back in my court if I
don't die this might hurt a lot and I
have to go through a really tough climb
just to get back to capable and it's an
even harder pill to swallow that
sometimes we feel the setback is out of
our control but the recovery is on us
and that's a lot to take that's hard and
that's life and you know what that never
changes let me give you another example
from from this crash that it will
hopefully explain it um again to explain
a lot of the crap to unpack that I'm not
proud of as it relates to ego right
after the accident my friend Johnny boy
was driving was shaking okay my vitals
were fine his blood pressure was was
through the roof I could tell he was out
of it and in the past oppa doesn't mind
me sharing this like I asked him before
he I know that he has had absence
seizures when he was young so I was very
worried about him because he was he was
shaking so our wives Tim and Manny who
work with us they're fantastic they they
came and got us off the freeway went to
a nearby McDonald's right away I said
johnny has to go home send him home and
remember telling my wife and the team
that I was pretty much fine and I just
needed a moment to gather my bearings it
was a lie
I lied I did not feel fine and I said to
them that I thought I could still go
down the AIDS Walk and do the whole day
of filming I said I just needed a minute
it reminds me of that scene and if you
ever saw the film regarding Henry did
you ever see regarding Henry yeah it's
where Harrison Ford gets shot and I
think it's the most accurate depiction
of the kind of shock in that scenario
ever put on screen maybe along with
captain Phillips that was really good
too but Harrison Ford is that a
committee start getting a pack of smokes
and a guy holding up the store he just
demands his wallet and shoots him
and Harrison Ford is he doesn't spin
over like a in a spaghetti western or he
doesn't scream in pain he just hold up
his hand and he you know the Harrison
for you know only wait wait wait a
minute wait a minute you just holding oh
hold on hold on a minute he falls over
in shock and he's bleeding he was shot
and it's almost more impactful when you
watch this because you think that's
probably how someone might react dad's
how I felt at the McDonald's of that
appointment I was saying I'm fine I just
need to take a second but the adrenaline
dump stopped and I'm pretty sure the
airbag boxed my right ear because I
couldn't hear all day it was it was
ringing just so that yeah high-pitched
ringing like in Saving Private Ryan I
couldn't hear on my right ear for the
rest of the day and that was my
equivalent of said well hold on a minute
I was sore I was tired I couldn't hear I
didn't feel fine you know why I lied
because of you go I was thinking of the
people depending on me the people that
we employ here the idea that this story
would circulate and that they would
maybe say oh man you know Steven was
such a such a trooper he went on down he
finished the segment anyway and so I
lied and I said it was fine but I
remember when I was saying it I was
looking to my wife and I think we've all
done this at some point was looking at
my wife for the I saying I'm not fine
I'm not fine step in here call it don't
let me go because I wanted to prove that
I could do it but if my wife said no
you're going home well guys that's
that's out of my that's out of my hands
let's see the point here is I realize
that I wanted my limitations to be set
by someone else I wanted my defeat or
what I perceived is my defeat to be out
of my control because otherwise people
would see me as a quitter
the truth is in not being honest in
lying to myself and my team about what I
could or couldn't control that was in a
way that was more of quitting what would
have been less of a quitters mentality
would have been to say guys I can't hear
you
my neck hurts I'm tired I'm going home
we'll live to fight another day because
that would have been taking ownership
the situation myself but instead I just
wanted to say no no I can do it I can do
this and I was looking for anyone else
anyone else to take me out for me and
that's the mentality of wanting to
absolve myself the responsibility of
accepting and recognizing my own
limitations and I was I was doing it all
over again just like the crash that the
bargain was god if you want to cry if I
why that's fine that's on you just
please don't let me live and be a
vegetable because that's on me and
that's gonna suck and it'll be
embarrassing
in this scenario it's in hey if my wife
calls it if one of you calls it that's
on you there's nothing I can do if you
don't it's on me and I'm gonna have to
grit my teeth and bear it and it being
on me is hard because that means now
I've got a decision to make a decision
to recognize my limitations and chart a
realistic course of action to recognize
what I could not do now here's that
here's the thing Manny and Tim they
decided to call it they said no you're
going home because they're good people
and I'll tell you I felt relief but that
doesn't change that I was lying to
myself they didn't decide for me I let
them decide for me because through ego I
basically abandoned my post so my
challenge to you is this think of how
often you do this particularly the young
men out there how often do you look for
a reason to lie to yourself to present
this facade of things being out of your
control just to avoid admitting your
weaknesses have you done it well you
know I guarantee you have I guarantee
you'll do it this week could be as
severe as what I went through or much
more severe than way or it could be as
simple as up you know I was I was late
traffic on the freeway it's that's out
of my hands there's nothing I can do is
it do you often find yourself running
late are you really Superman do you make
promises you can't keep why and what I
want you to do is rather than wait until
a crisis occurs so you can throw up your
hands and chalk it up to being out of
your control I want you to take
inventory right now what are your
limitations what are your weaknesses
your quiet time take a minute take
inventory because guess what it's okay
it's okay that limitations it's okay to
have weaknesses it's okay to be honest
about them this is where we get it wrong
it's not okay to celebrate them we don't
need to celebrate our weaknesses but
it's good to work on them and there are
many things in life that we can't
control
but I think we all want to bear a little
less responsibility than we probably
should sometimes here's something you
can control you can control right now
recognizing your weaknesses recognizing
your limitations and accepting the
incremental improvements that you can
make to correct them but you can you can
never know what that is this is
something to we'll talk about this a lot
with with knowing what the hard door is
knowing what the easy out is in
recognizing you can never know you will
never know what your potential is
what you're capable of truly
accomplishing if you're lying to
yourself because of ego the guy who
claims you can do it all and can't okay
is a far less value than the man who can
look you in the eye and say you know
what I I know that I can do this because
I know that I can't do that so I can
tell you about any any shadow of a doubt
because I know I can't do that I know I
can do this that's what the world needs
more that's a realness we get it wrong a
lot that's an experiment with you this
week turns out don't crash
[Music]